time now for the uplifted eight stories  that will bring you some joy some joy to  your day mr duties here that's a good  start already what do you got all right  so every day at 8 20 we do this story i  always say to people it's going to be  the best thing you're going to see all  day so you've probably heard this  legendary sam cook song many many times  but i bet you've never heard it quite  like this  [Applause]  [Music]  it's been a long  time coming  yeah i know i know a change is going to  come that warm voice belongs to  ten-year-old jordan christian holland he  blew people away with this powerful  performance of a change is going to come  at a local talent show in shreveport  louisiana jordan left the talent show  with two awards in that video of his  performance folks has gotten more than  three million views on tick tock wow  future he is a record dude this is about  to say my man's got a few yeah you got  to have an old soul to sing that that  was really  coming up